[Musik]
[Gelächter]
im Sommer des Jahres 1953 nehmen in dem
kleinen Fischerort minamata im Süden
Japans ungewöhnliche Ereignisse ihren
Lauf
zunächst spricht man von den tanzenden
Katzen doch wenig später gehen bei der
örtlichen Gesundheitsbehörde Berichte
von Menschen ein die ähnliche Symptome
zeigen
die Universität von minamata findet
schließlich heraus dass sie sich bei der
Erkrankung um eine Funktionsstörung des
zentralen Nervensystems handelt
als Ursache wird eine chronische
Quecksilbervergiftung diagnostiziert
in den folgenden Jahren kommen in der
Umgebung von minamata zahlreiche
missgebildete Kinder zur Welt
über Jahre hatte der Chemiekonzern
Tissot quecksilberhaltige
schwermetallabfälle direkt ins Meer
geleitet
trotz dieser Ereignisse bleibt
Quecksilber weiterhin allgemein in
Verwendung
Quecksilbervergiftungen epidemischen
Ausmaßes sind wiederholt die Folge
[Musik]
erst im Jahr 2009 werden die Vereinten
Nationen aktiv
[Musik]
man beschließt zumindest die technische
Nutzung von Quecksilber weltweit zu
verbieten
[Musik]
quecksilberhaltige Geräte werden auf
staatliche Anordnung aus den Haushalten
entfernt
mit einer Ausnahme die Leuchtstofflampe
sie darf weiterhin Quecksilber enthalten
zunächst schien es einfach einen Beitrag
zum Klimaschutz zu leisten und wer will
nicht bei der Rettung des Planeten
mithelfen jeder konnte dabei sein
durch das Einschrauben einer Lampe einer
energiespannung
aber bald tauchten
gefährde ich also mit Sparlampen meine
Familie
oder rette ich die Erde
was ist wichtiger und was muss für das
höhere Ziel im Kauf genommen werden
wo liegt die Wahrheit
ich schließe dort nachzufragen wo ich
bisher meine Lampen gekauft habe
bei Ikea
kommen anderer Konzern bringt mehr
Energiesparlampen mit Umlauf aus der
schwedische Möbelhersteller
bereits im Jahr 2010 stoppte Ikea den
Verkauf von herkömmlichen Glühlampen
vollständig
[Musik]
weil positive
keine direkte Gefahr wenn eine Sparlampe
zerbricht
ich höre von einem Kind in Bayern das in
Kontakt mit einer zerbrochenen Sparlampe
gekommen ist
ein Missgeschick dessen katastrophale
Auswirkungen für den Vierjährigen Max
sich erst Wochen später zeigen
wir hatten hier am Boden eine eine
Stehleuchte stehen die natürlich
gebrannt hat mit einer Energiesparlampe
drin
und wie es so ist man man läuft hin und
her und irgendwann ist diese Lampe
umgefallen und zwar in Richtung
Schlafzimmers wir gehen davon aus dass
der dass der Quecksilberdampf der in
dieser Lampe war sich in den
Räumlichkeiten hier ausgebreitet hat
also sprich in das angrenzende
Schlafzimmer sozusagen von uns und das
Ganze ist am Nachmittag so zwischen 4
und 5 passiert
Familie Laus ist in einer Ersatzwohnung
bei Nachbarn untergekommen
ihr eigenes Haus ist nach den
Ereignissen im Januar 2010 unbewohnbar
es war Winter wo das passiert mit dieser
Energiesparlampe zwei drei Wochen später
Kinder kommen natürlich vom vom vom
Schneemann bauen draußen rein mit Mütze
und alles und viele Mütze haben halt
runtergemacht und und in der Mütze waren
immer die Haare drin und am Anfang jetzt
nur nichts so auffällig aber immer mehr
und immer mehr
und
ja es ging dann so weit dass man die
Haare nehmen konnte und einfach so so
wegziehen sage ich mal ja rausziehen und
es wurden immer mehr kahle Stellen am
Kopf bisschen zum kompletten Haarverlust
wiederum einige Wochen später hat es
damit den Augenbrauen stattgefunden dann
mit dem Wimpern die nicht mehr da waren
und eben Wochen später dass er immer so
zitterschieber bekommen hat das heißt
das ist auch sein morgenlicher Körper
das wenn er den so hält dass er dann
wirklich so zittert und einfach ja
verschlabbert fängt halt einfach an ihn
auch zu Fuchsen ja das merkt er dass
irgendwas mit ihm nicht stimmt und er
kann so nicht richtig einsortieren und
es ist
halt irgendwie getan wird was man
dagegen machen kann
folgender weiterhelfen
die gesundheitlichen Folgen sind noch
nicht absehbar die Auswirkungen auf
seinen Alltag bekommt Maxi doch
unmittelbar zu spüren ich muss sagen der
Kindergarten selbst ist sehr sehr gut
mit dem Thema umgegangen
es war am Anfang eine kurze scheue
allerdings die die Kindergärtnerin haben
die Kinder dann letztendlich darauf
vorbereitet dass der Maxi jetzt eben
krank ist aber nicht nicht ansteckend
und diese diese scheue hat sich dann mit
der Zeit gegeben was aber trotzdem sehr
sehr auffällig ist immer wieder einfach
neue Kinder die erkennen lernt oder
einfach dass das Eltern auf einen
zugehen und und und direkt darauf
ansprechen das merkt er und und da merkt
er dann immer wieder dass er einfach
ja anders ist wie andere Kinder und das
kriegt auch zu spielen
nach einer Odyssee von Arzt zu Arzt
beschließt die Familie dass ich der
Zustand von Max nicht bessert einen
Spezialisten für Quecksilbervergiftungen
aufzusuchen
die Energiesparlampe ist im brennenden
Zustand zerbrochen
das bedeutet das natürlich
merkwechselbar in freier Dampfform
vorliegt und wenn die dann zerbricht
kommt halt mehr raus als wenn man den
kalten Zustand zerbricht
wenn so ein Ereignis ist ist natürlich
schon offensichtlich dass diese
Quecksilberbelastung diese Sache jetzt
der ausgelöst hat weil vor war gesünder
und dann ist aber trotzdem so das
natürlich vielleicht schon in gewisse
Basis da war von anderen
Belastungsfaktoren wo die Gesundheit
auch zumindest mal steht der
tropfenhülle den Stein und jetzt ist
aber auch für die Therapie so dass wir
versuchen müssen auch alle anderen
Faktoren zu berücksichtigen so gut wie
möglich zu eliminieren ich würde jetzt
anhand dieser Daten die Sie mir jetzt
schon gesagt haben gezeigt haben würde
ich befürworten dass man auch eine
Quecksilber ausladungstherapie macht
jetzt mal tief einatmen
und jetzt Ausatmen ganz fest zack
wie wirkt Quecksilber im Körper wo kommt
es hin und was richtet es dort an
das Labor für chemische und
mikrobiologische Analytik lavoo
untersucht Wohnräume auf Giftstoffe und
krank machende Substanzen
wir haben also ungefähr 1000 Anfragen
pro Jahr von Menschen die irgendwie
Probleme in den Gebäuden haben 900 von
denen rufen an weil sie schon krank sind
keiner weiß warum der größte Teil hat
eine Leidensgeschichte wo sie viele
Ärzte Krankenhausaufenthalte Kuren
Medikamente und so weiter hinter sich
haben und keiner irgendwo meine Frage
stellt haben sie dort vielleicht
wohngift oder Schwermetalle von denen
sie krank werden können diese ganz
einfache Frage die ist einfach in vielen
Bereichen dieser Gesellschaft Mangelware
und deswegen werden auch viele immer
kränker ohne zu wissen wovon sie
eigentlich krank werden
[Musik]
wenn die DNA irgendwo angegriffen ist
und ein Schaden hat repariert der
Körperteils dasselbe aber durch
Quecksilber kann der Körper das nicht
mehr reparieren so ist dadurch alle
anderen Stoffe also Chemikalien das
können also krank machen oder
krebserregende Chemikalien sein aber
auch andere die dann plötzlich wirken
können so dass dann in
kombinationswirkung ganz schwere
Erkrankungen praktisch der
kombinationswirkungen mit Quecksilber
resultieren können man hat Ratten
genommen und versuchen und hat sozusagen
die letale Dosis an Blei gegeben die
Menge an Blei wo ein Prozent der Ratten
gestorben ist und dann hat man praktisch
die Dosis bestimmt von Quecksilber bei
der auch nur ein Prozent der Ratten
stirbt als ein Prozent der hatten
gestorben und dann haben folgendes
Versuch gemacht und hat praktisch jetzt
beide Sachen gegeben man hat die Menge
von Blei gegeben wo ein Prozent der
Ratten stirbt und plus die Menge
Quecksilber wo ein Prozent der Ratten
stirbt zusammen in einer Ratten
Population und was man eigentlich was da
gestorben ist das sind 100% gestorben
das heißt im Endeffekt bedeutet das dass
1 + 1 = 100 definitoxikologie
der Universität Calgary gelang es
erstmals zu zeigen wie Nervenzellen von
Quecksilber direkt angegriffen und
zerstört werden
[Musik]
jedes quecksilberatome richtet den
Schaden an und erreichen eben ganz
geringe Mengen um böse Krankheiten
auszulösen und gerade als
Quecksilberdampf ist es extrem toxisch
weil dieser Quecksilberdampf über die
Atmung praktisch komplett resorbiert
wird und dieses Quecksilber kommt nicht
sofort wieder raus sondern wird in
andere Körperorgane eingeschleust vor
allem muss man sagen die Niere die
Drüsen und vor allem auch das Gehirn und
dort bleibt es mehrere Jahrzehnte oder
noch länger und das reichert sich eben
an und macht immer ein bisschen mehr
krank und jedes kleinste bisschen
Quecksilber macht ein klein bisschen
dünner weil es ja das Gehirn angreift
wie viel Quecksilber ist in einer
Energiesparlampe enthalten
die von der EU zum Marktüberwachung
vorgesehene Messmethode erfordert das
Zerstören der Lampe sie wird in Stücke
geschnitten und Säure zersetzt und
analysiert
die Methode hat allerdings eine
entscheidende Schwäche nur die flüssigen
Anteile des Quecksilbers werden gemessen
die gasförmigen entweichen
ja also das kommt mir so vor als würde
man den heliumgehalt eines eines
Luftballons dadurch bestimmen wollen
dass man dass man in zerplatzen lässt
und nachher die die Gummihaut zu Analyse
führt und sagt und jetzt sagt mir wie
viel wie viel Helium der ursprünglich
drinnen war das funktioniert natürlich
nicht
im Forschungsreaktor des Wiener
atominstituts hat Georg Steinhauser eine
Messanordnung vorbereitet die zu
verlässlichen Ergebnissen führt
die Lampe bleibt dabei unbeschädigt kein
Quecksilber kann nicht weichen
ich möchte eine Sparlampe der Familie
Laus auf ihren Quecksilbergehalt
untersuchen lassen
sie wurde zugleich mit der zerbrochenen
gekauft und bis heute aufbewahrt selber
Hersteller
die Lampe wird in den Reaktor
hinabgelassen wo sie mit Neutronen
bestrahlt wird
dadurch wird das Quecksilber in der
lampe-
diese Strahlungsmenge entspricht exakt
der Quecksilbermenge der Lampe
unterliegt die Quecksilbermenge in
Energiesparlampen irgendwelchen
Beschränkungen
der europaweit größte Hersteller von
kompakt Leuchtstofflampen ist mega Man
ich hoffe dort mehr zu erfahren wir
haben eine EU-Regelung und da ist eine
klare Deckelung bei diesem
Quecksilbergehalt vorhanden ist das der
Verbraucher kann sich auch sowieso
darauf verlassen dass dieser
maximalgehalt von 5 mg auf keinen Fall
bei einem marktkonform zulässigen
Produkt überschritten wird
[Musik]
warum gerade 5 Milligramm
produktionstechnische Notwendigkeiten
scheinen bei der Festlegung dieses
Grenzwertes Vorrang vor
Gesundheitsrisiken gehabt zu haben
die Menge des verwendeten Quecksilbers
kann schwanken
auf welche Weise aber können am Markt
befindliche Lampen die sogar diesen
Quecksilber Grenzwert überschreiten aus
dem Verkehr gezogen werden wer
kontrolliert
grundsätzlich kontrolliert es gibt kein
das EU-System besteht so in dem Moment
der Hersteller der Importeur garantiert
durch die Bezeichnung ce das ein
produktmarktkonform ist das ist eine
Grundsatz man geht also von einer
Politik von von Treu und Glauben aus
jetzt gibt es natürlich kriminelle
Hersteller die sich daran nicht halten
das ist schlecht es gibt aber Falschgeld
das ist auch schlecht und trotzdem wird
nicht jeder Geldscheinen einzeln
nachkontrolliert
[Musik]
bevor die EU das Verschwinden der
Glühlampe verordnete ließ sie von der
belgischen Firma Vito eine vorbereitende
Studie erstellen
diese Studie war Basis und Grundlage für
die Verordnung
dort findet sich auch die Untersuchung
von Sparlampen auf ihren Quecksilber
gehalten
sie beschränkt sie sich allerdings auf
fünf Stück das kann ein Scherz sein das
entbehrt jeder wissenschaftlichen
Grundlage dass man dass man mit einem
mit einer Sample Größe von von fünf
Stück
auch nur annähernd eine verlässliche
Aussage bekommen möchte
selbst von diesen fünf Stück
überschreitet eine die höchst zulässige
Quecksilbermenge von 5 mg
es ist da offenbar mehr Willkür als als
wissenschaftliche Seriosität am Werk
gewesen
ich habe die Möglichkeit Geld geladen
den ehemaligen Präsidenten des
internationalen lichtdesignerverbandes
zu treffen
die Lady beteiligte sich an den
EU-internen Diskussionen die dem Ende
der Glühlampe vorangehen
er repräsentierte in der eingesetzten
Arbeitsgruppe die Lichtdesigner und
hatte so Einblick in die Abläufe der
europäischen Gesetzgebung
[Musik]
die Vorreiterrolle beim Umstieg auf
effizientere Leuchtmittel kann das
umweltbewusste Europa nicht für sich in
Anspruch nehmen
[Musik]
kein demokratischer Staat kann das
nein Kuba ist das erste Land der Welt
das zur Gänze auf leuchtstoffpflicht
umgestellt hat
[Musik]
für die restlose Beseitigung aller
Glühlampen sorgten junge Männer im Zuge
der Revolution
zwei von ihnen zeigen mir wie sie damals
im Auftrag des Regimes vorzugehen hatten
wie weit aber ist das moderne Europa mit
dem sogenannten Glühlampenverbot das
auch direkt in die Haushalte seiner
Bürger eingreift von solchen
autokratischen Praktiken entfernt
was in Diktaturen ein leichtes ist ließ
sich auch in Europa in Gang bringen
der einzige EU-Parlamentarier der sich
von Beginn an gegen das Verschwinden der
Glühlampe auflehnt ist ein deutscher
Holger Kramer kann sich mit seiner
Position im Parlament jedoch nicht
durchsetzen
wer entscheidet darüber ob die
Entscheidung eines Verbrauchers jetzt
richtig oder falsch ist
allein darüber politische moralische
Werturteile abzugeben ist eine
hochfragbare Angelegenheit
ich komme aus der früheren DDR ich habe
dort
zentralistische Diktatur erlebt damals
wurde auf Parteitagen in
Fünfjahresplänen beschlossen wie viel
Farbfernseher und wie viel
Rasierapparate oder DDR-Bevölkerung zur
Verfügung gestellt worden muss sagen im
Jahr 20 nach dem Mauerfall und
eigentlich das froh sein aber gewonnene
Freiheiten erinnert mich vieles von dem
was die EU-Kommission heute hier macht
ein Politbüro das ist das hat
diktatorische Züge
[Musik]
[Applaus]
es ist
schon eine sehr
gefährliche Entwicklung dass wir
administratoren haben Bürokraten haben
die sich aus dem EU Vertrag oder eben
auch aus dem Rechtsakt die Möglichkeit
ableiten über unsere Köpfe hinweg eine
Entscheidung zu treffen
im Juli 2005 wird von der Europäischen
Kommission die sogenannte
ökodesignrichtlinie erlassen
diese Richtlinie soll die umweltgerechte
Gestaltung Energie-
in dem umfangreichen Gesetzestext finden
sich zahlreiche Produktgruppen an denen
künftig Energieeinsparungsmaßnahmen
durchzuführen sind
in lediglich einen kurzen Nebensatz wird
die Beleuchtung in privaten Haushalten
erwähnt
ein Nebensatz von immenser Bedeutung
denn er sollte das Ende der Glühlampe
zur Folge haben
die EU-Kommission hat auf Basis der Öko
des einrichtlinie das
energieverbrauchende Produkt Glühbirne
genommen und gemäß dem Gesetzestext
Energieeffizienzkriterien definiert die
dann faktisch eben ein produktverbot
nach sich gezogen haben weil eben die
klassische Glühbirne diese Kriterien
nicht mehr erfüllt hat
dieses Glühlampenverbot wird in einem
sogenannten komythologie Verfahren
beschlossen ein politischer Prozess der
für gewöhnlich dazu dient die
Durchführung europäischer Gesetze im
Detail zu regeln
zunächst wird eine Arbeitsgruppe ein
kommythologieausschuss gebildet dazu
entsenden die Betroffenen Ministerien
aus den 27 Mitgliedsstaaten fachlich
kompetente Beamte neben ihnen beteiligen
sich Vertreter der Industrie NGOs und
andere Experten an den regelmäßigen
Meetings der Arbeitsgruppe
beauftragte Studien werden diskutiert
Fragen aufgeworfen und abgehandelt
schließlich wird im Ausschuss abgestemmt
das Ergebnis der Abstimmung die
kommythologie Entscheidung wird zur
Kontrolle an das Europäische Parlament
gesandt
nimmt dieses sein Vetorecht nicht in
Anspruch gilt die kommythologie
Entscheidung als angenommen
dieses Verfahren hat allerdings ein
grundsätzliches Problem
im Europäischen Parlament wird über eine
kometologieentscheidung nur dann
abgestimmt wenn sich eine Mehrheit
findet und diese Abstimmung einfordert
andernfalls findet im Parlament keine
Abstimmung statt die kommythologie
Entscheidung wird so fast automatisch zu
Verordnung und ist damit europaweit
gesetzt
[Musik]
wir sind hier
Entscheidungsprozessen ausgeliefert die
sich irgendeiner transparenten
geschweige denn demokratischen Kontrolle
völlig entziehen und das ist sind Dinge
die unser alltägliches Leben betreffen
the band ist definitely very
strong Marketing
Propaganda
Marketing the propaganda around the
compact Florence
as probably influence many people
hey hey energiesparten die Bilder
[Musik]
zum Energiesparen jede Form
was machst du Bruno ich rufe fertig
die Industrie versucht nicht nur
Konsumenten sondern vor allem politische
Entscheidungsträger zu beeinflussen ich
befrage den Wirtschaftswissenschaftler
Max Otte über das Verhältnis zwischen
Politik und Industrie ich kann mir sehr
gut vorstellen dass die Politik
instrumentalisiert worden ist das geht
ja auch über die EU Gremien sehr gut die
Brüssel ist sehr intransparent da kann
man im Vorfeld schon viel Einfluss
nehmen also warum soll nicht die
Lichtindustrie mit der Politik dasselbe
machen was die Bankbranche mit der
Politik gemacht hat nämlich letztlich
sich die eigenen Regeln selber
geschrieben hat und die Politik das
ganze dann abgelegt hat es gibt
unendlich viele Möglichkeiten wie
natürlich Geld Einfluss nehmen kann ohne
dass man direkt von Bestechung sprechen
kann
man müsste transparent darlegen nach
welchen Kriterien diese Arbeitsgruppen
zusammengestellt werden also wie kommt
es dass da einem 30-40 Personen
Arbeitsgruppe
zwei große glühlampenhersteller am Tisch
sitzen wenn es die dann Entscheidung
treffen auch die wird ja nicht bloß
konsultiert die dann am Ende ein Produkt
Entscheidung erlassen das heißt also
dass die der direkte Einfluss von
ökonomischen Interessen auf eine
politische Entscheidung erheblich groß
nee
Philips wir haben in Europa plus noch
zwei maßgebliche große Hersteller von
Glühlampen Philips und natürlich saßen
die da dabei und haben natürlich an der
Stelle das Geschäft gewittert ne das
probably just a economical consideration
die ganz wenigen Produkte die eigentlich
für alle in der Prozesskette Beteiligten
Strategie darstellt da hat der Konsument
was davon da hat die Ökologie was davon
und der das verkauft und hat was davon
auch was davon wir haben über 400
Modelle das hat bisher keine fertig
gebracht und die meisten Innovationen
die ist der EU überhaupt möglich gemacht
haben
Energiesparlampen hervorzuheben und
Glühlampenverbot auszusprechen sind
unsere Innovation gewesen für mich ist
dieses Europa ein Europa der Konzerne
das heißt die Konzerne haben schon
längst die
Herrschaft übernommen in vielen täglich
Bereichen des täglichen Lebens und ähm
gerade was die Regulierungsfragen
bei Branchen und Industrien angeht ist
der Einfluss der Konzerne doch in
Ordnung
im Herbst 2009 ist es der deutsche
bundesumweltminister Sigmar Gabriel der
ein potenzielle Wählerinnen und Wähler
5000 Kontakt leicht zu Flammen der Firma
Ausland verteilt
kritischen Fragen zu dieser Aktion war
ich da aus was ist über allen Produkten
das ist schon gucken auch wenn sie sich
ein Auto kaufen oder ein Kühlschrank
oder ein Fahrrad ob das was die Werbung
gibt auch gehalten wird das relativ
einfach das zu überprüfen
[Musik]
Gabriels Kontakte zu Lichtindustrie ist
eine Haltung den Sparlampen gegenüber
positiv beeinflusst haben
[Musik]
und jetzt ist das Interview zu Ende weil
das sind meine Gäste sie tschüss
die Geschichte der Lichtindustrie ist
von Beginn an mit Absprachen verbunden
die Konzerne wollen einander nicht
unnötig Konkurrenz machen
die erste weltweite Aushebung von
Wettbewerb ist das geheime
föubungskartell
1924 haben sich verschiedene Vertreter
von internationalen getroffen um nichts
weniger als den gesamten Weltmarkt unter
sich aufzuteilen
natürlich gewesen weil man ja darauf
hingearbeitet hat die Profite zu
maximieren das ist gut ist wenn man den
Verbraucher nicht allzu viel Licht
überhaupt gibt sprich eine Glühlampe hat
eine bestimmte Lebensdauer wie hier auf
diesen lebensdauer-
und natürlich ging es darum diese
Lebensdauer entsprechend nach unten
abzusenken an einen Beschluss gefasst
schon ein Jahr nachdem sich führungs
gegründet hatte und hat gesagt naja dann
geben wir den Verbraucher einfach nur
1000 Stunden brennend
[Musik]
ein Teil der internen Aufzeichnungen von
föbus ist bis heute erhalten geblieben
die Verwaltungsakten des
kartell-mitglieds Osram dem heute
größten Lampenhersteller Deutschlands
die Dokumente befinden sich im
Landesarchiv Berlin
tausende von Seiten
Korrespondenz mit den Kartellen
Mitgliedern Einwände und und auch
Protokolle der Sitzung und der
Ausschüsse
also ich habe auch Leute angeschrieben
bei Osram Siemens
über die Kartell Vergangenheit da
will man nicht wissen das ist so wie
wenn der Opa bei Nazis war oder so ne
Opa was
Quatsch so so ist so wird das behandelt
aber leugnen sie das ja also die leugnen
in dem Sinne dass sie sagen das ist
Spinnerei
das mit den tausend Stunden
regelmäßig berichtet Helmut Höge der
sich seit Jahren mit der Geschichte der
Glühlampe beschäftigt in der Berliner
Tat zu dem Thema
jetzt geht es darum was machen wir mit
den Konzernen die Mitglieder bei uns
sind und die Lampen herstellen die
weiter über 1000 Stunden brennen
also die Hersteller die
birnenfabriken die
unter weit
unterläsident aus liefern oder
herstellen werden nicht bestraft also
bestraft wird nur wer ganz explizit
werden Lampen produziert über 1000
Stunden halten und wenn das jemand ist
der nicht
Kartell ist dann gibt es auch dafür dann
Maßnahmen wie man mit dem zu verfahren
hat dass das nicht passiert
ja also es gab natürlich immer wieder
kleinere Firmen die nicht unbedingt die
Kraft gehabt haben sich in diesem
Kartell einzugliedern die ein bisschen
wie das gallische Dorf versucht haben
sich gegen eine große Übermacht zu
wehren und möglicherweise ist Merkur
ähnlich aufgestellt gewesen dass man
versucht hat der großen Übermacht dieses
Kartells zu entfliehen
Glühlampe hat 5000 Stunden gebrannt ist
dementsprechend 4000 Stunden über dem
vom füllbus seiner Zeit
verlautbarten soll und man kann sich
vielleicht ausmalen dass merkur ist
sicherlich nicht besonders beliebt
gewesen im Rahmen dieses Hotels
es war also von vornherein ein großer
Betrug den sie da
angefangen mit der Reduzierung der
Lebensdauer bis hin zu allen
Werbemaßnahmen und also grauenhaft
heute sind die bedeutendsten
Lampenhersteller in der European Lamb
companies Federation kurz
Osram und fünf weitere
gemeinsam sind diese Konzerne für 95%
der europäischen lampenproduktion
verantwortlich
nach eigen Definition berät die ihr sie
die Behörden bei der Entwicklung
europäischer Gesetze die für die
Lichtindustrie von Bedeutung sind
Glühlampen für den privaten Gebrauch
werden aus dem Katalogen der Hersteller
bald verschwunden sein
zu Beginn des 20 Jahrhunderts aber
entsteht in Berlin ein ganzer Stadtteil
aus Fabrikationshallen in denen das neue
elektrische Licht hergestellt wird
eine Glühlampe ist etwas besonderes
die nahegelegene zwingli-kirche wird
schnell als Werbeträgerin entdeckt
diese Kirche ist im unmittelbarer
Umgebung von Berlins Lichterstadt dem
alten osramwerk mal gebaut worden und
als die Kirche schon fast fertig war
kamen die Vorstände von Osram und sagten
aber wenn das schon die Kirche in
unserem Rücken ist wollen wir doch auch
stolz unser neues Produkt die Glühlampe
zeigen und auch ausstellen also haben
sie den Architekten gezwungen auf die
Architektur so etwas draufzusetzen einen
merkwürdiges Jugendstil Element und
wichtig war dass die Birne auf jeden
Fall zu sehen ist nicht verdeckt ist
heute macht uns das natürlich das
Problem dass diese Glühlampen ja nun
demnächst nicht mehr existieren werden
was soll man machen
doch es gibt immer wieder Versuche die
verkürzte Lebensdauer von Glühlampen
wieder zu erhöhen so etwa durch den
Berliner Erfinder dieser bininger der
Mitte der 70er Jahre am Kurfürstendamm
eine Mengen leere Uhr errichtet hatte um
die erheblichen Kosten für den Austausch
kaputter Glühlampen zu verringern
beginnt bininger mit der Arbeit an einer
Lampe die nie kaputt gehen sollte wir
hatten natürlich zunächst die
Forschungsabteilung von Osram in Berlin
um Hilfe gebeten und wir haben
schriftlich das ist keinerlei
Möglichkeiten gibt die Lebensdauer von
Glühlampen zu erhöhen dann muss an
entschlossen einen eigenen Weg zu gehen
und haben dann einen Weg gefunden
die Lebensdauer von Glühlampen zu
erhöhen wohlgemerkt bei gleichem
Verbrauch und gleicher Helligkeit und
dafür haben wir dann auch ein Patent
bekommen
biningers langen Lebensdauer Glühlampen
brennen 150.000 Stunden
sie werden in den Kandelabern rund um
die Berliner Siegessäule getestet ohne
jeden Ausfall
ja ist es denn nicht schwierig überhaupt
frage ich ein Produkt herzustellen das
um so viel länger haltbar ist wie man
die Industrie muss ja auch verkaufen
hält Arbeitsplätze sind nicht zu
verstehen ja das ist natürlich zu
verstehen
da geht es um Hunderte von Millionen von
Glühlampen wenn wir jetzt einfach
hingehen und können diesen
wechselrhythmus nur um Faktor 3 oder 4
reduzieren dann gehen das geht um so
viel Geld dass der Spaß dann nun
wirklich aufhört die langen Lebensdauer
Glühlampen sollten nie in
Massenproduktion gehen vier Tage nachdem
Binninger ein Übernahmeangebot für ein
ehemals ostdeutsches lampenwerk
abgegeben hat stürzte mit seinem
Privatflugzeug ab Dieter bininger ist
auf der Stelle tot
heute
Glühlampe in Vergessenheit geraten die
Mengenlehre Uhr steht nicht mehr am
Kurfürstendamm und in ihr brennen
Energiesparlampen
auch sie müssen regelmäßig erneuert
werden
im Auftrag von Händlern und
Verbrauchermagazinen testet Wolfgang
härter verschiedenste Lampen auf
Haltbarkeit Sicherheit und
Funktionstüchtigkeit
vielleicht schaut mal jemand zu Hause
nach wenn er irgendwo noch alte
Glühlampen findet das findet man
durchaus mal eine Angabe von 5000
Stunden
das gibt es auch noch aus dem ich habe
Lampen aus den 70er Jahren dort finde
ich also ein Aufdruck 5000 Stunden bis
heute werden spezialampen hergestellt
die die Lebensdauer herkömmlicher
Glühlampen bei weitem übertreffen
16.000 Stunden sind nicht ungewöhnlich
an Privathaushalte werden diese Lampen
jedoch nicht verkauft die EU verbietet
es
wir aber sieht es mit der Lebensdauer
von Energiesparlampen aus
die Angaben bei den Dauerhaltbarkeit die
der deklariert sind auf der Packung die
werden teilweise auch weit
unterschritten so wir haben zum Beispiel
auch bei einem Markenhersteller Dauer
Haltbarkeit getestet und kamen da noch
nicht mal das 5000 Stunden
Packungen sind dann 10.000 Stunden
angegeben
der auf einer lampenpackung angegebene
Wert für die Lebensdauer besagt nicht
dass diese Energiesparlampe mindestens
so lange funktionieren wird
es ist auch kein Wert für die
durchschnittliche Lebenserwartung der
Lampe er beschreibt nichts anderes als
jenen Zeitraum nachdem unter
Laborbedingungen gerade noch die Hälfte
der getesteten Lampen brennt
[Musik]
ich denke das ist ein Werbeargument zum
Vergleich zur Glühlampe denn wenn ich
jetzt ins Regal gehe und mal die Packung
studiere da finde ich auf der Glühlampe
eine Angabe von 1000 Stunden das ist
natürlich nicht sehr viel und wenn ich
dann Energiesparlampe dagegen sehe
10.000 Stunde das ist eindeutig das
bessere Produkt als Laie würde ich das
so erstmal sehen
[Musik]
die Energiesparlampe hat viele
Einzelteile
wir haben uns hier mal die Mühe gemacht
mal eine Energie
und von dieser Leiterplatte das sind
normal die Bauteile drauf mal die
Bauteile abzulösen und man sieht hier
sind über 30 Bauteile Graphit Halbleiter
Silizium viel Kunststoff natürlich
Verhältnis zu Glühlampe immens viel der
Fertigungsprozess ist also doch sehr
kompliziert
eine Energiesparlampe im Fachbegriff
kompakt Leuchtstofflampe genannt ist im
Grunde nichts anderes als eine
verkleinerte gebogene Leuchtstoffröhre
mit schraubfassung der Sockel enthält
ein elektronisches Vorschaltgerät dass
die zur Zündung notwendige Hochspannung
erzeugt und dann den ansonsten
unkontrolliert anschwellenden Stromfluss
drosselt
zunächst wird ein Glühfaden erhitzt
wodurch das in der Lampe befindliche
Quecksilber vom flüssigen in den
gasförmigen Zustand übergeht
unter Spannung beginnt es UV-Strahlung
auszusenden diese Strahlung ist für
Menschen jedoch nicht sichtbar der
Glaskolben ist deshalb innen mit einem
fluoreszierenden Pulver den
Leuchtstoffen beschichtet die
UV-Strahlen treffen auf diese Schicht
die im sichtbaren Bereich zu leuchten
beginnt
[Musik]
als baupiologe betreibt Wolfgang mes ein
Testinstitut dass wir Fachzeitschriften
und Verbraucherorganisationen Messungen
durchführt
er demonstriert mir Eigenschaften der
kompakt-
wir haben also verschiedene
Frequenzen in denen die Energiesparlampe
das Licht unterbricht und somit zu einem
Flimmereffekt führt das sieht man mit
dem Auge nicht mehr direkt weil das Auge
solche hohen Frequenzen nicht mehr
auflöst aber es ist da
was das last not least biologisch
bedeutet weiß natürlich wieso oft mal
wieder keiner aber es gibt eine ganze
Reihe von wissenschaftlichen Hinweisen
darauf dass es neurologisch wirksam ist
das ist ein Stressfaktor ist das ist ein
Risikofaktor ist Fazit die
Energiesparlampe macht ein Konglomerat
von verschiedenen flimmerfrequenzen wie
Sie sie bei der Glühbirne z.B oder bei
der Halogenbirne überhaupt nicht finden
man kann das genauso gut wie man das
optisch sichtbar machen kann auch
akustisch hörbar machen dafür schalte
ich jetzt mal ein Messgerät ein das
haben wir für diesen Zweck extra
entwickelt und schon hören wir dann
dieses
[Musik]
flimmende Chaos einer Energie
und wenn ich die jetzt ausmache und dann
sehen Sie sofort
das ist sie und jetzt werde ich die mal
wechseln und austauschen gegen eine
Glühbirne und bei gleicher Einstellung
dann zu zeigen dass das wirklich typisch
ist für Energiesparlampen
das Gerät ist nach wie vor eingestellt
ich bringe die zum Leuchten
und Fazit ist da passiert gar nichts
also der große Unterschied
Energiesparlampe zu Glühbirne
ist neben vielen anderen Aspekten über
die wir noch sprechen wem eine sehr sehr
starke Belastung durch Licht flimmern
wir sagen es schon seit Jahren und
weisen darauf hin und nicht nur die
Hersteller auch die Behörden auch die
Wissenschaftler teilweise sagen nein das
flimmert nicht mehr durch die
elektronischen Vorschaltgeräte haben wir
den Leuchtkörper und das Flimmern
ausgetrieben es wird immer wieder gesagt
aber sie können so oft sagen wie Sie
wollen es stimmt nicht es flimmert nicht
nur ein bisschen es flimmert in vielen
vielen verschiedenen Frequenzen sehr
ausgeprägt nach wie vor
kommen wir zum Elektrosmog die
elektromagnetischen feldbelastungen sind
bei den sparleuchten sehr viel
ausgeprägter als zum Beispiel bei
Glühbirnen
Bildschirme dürfen nicht mehr als ein
Volt pro Meter abgeben bei der Glühbirne
und bei der Halogenbirne haben wir gar
nichts die sind also Elektrosmog frei
und jetzt kommen wir zu den
Energiesparlampen und sehen hohe Balken
bis in den Bereich weit über 10 Volt pro
Meter das heißt wir haben an
Energiesparlampen wahrhaftig
elektrische feldbelastungen die wir
aushalten müssen und hoffentlich auch
können
die liegen beim zigfachen von
Computerarbeitsplatz genommen
wir etablieren hier eine neue Technik
die mit einer ganzen Reihe von
Nebenwirkungen aufwartet wir wissen
überhaupt nichts über die biologischen
Probleme wir wissen da ist eine Menge
wir wissen aber nicht was es bedeutet
wir wissen es gibt neurologische
Probleme immunologische Probleme
gesundheitlich relevante Probleme wir
wissen da verändert sich was in
biologischen geschehen da verändert sich
was im EEG des wissen wir alles aber wir
wissen last not least im Endeffekt nicht
was bedeutet es in Bezug auf macht krank
macht's nicht krank es wird eine
massentechnik vom Market ohne
Grundlagenforschung ohne Wissen um die
Konsequenzen
experimentierkaninchen Mensch
der Arzt und lichtbiologe Alexander
Wunsch setzt sich seit Jahren mit den
Wirkungen von Licht auf den menschlichen
Organismus auseinander er betont die
Wichtigkeit des vollständigen
Lichtspektrums der Sonne
und er diesem Licht haben wir uns
entwickelt und
irgendwelche Spektren aus dem
natürlichen aus der natürlichen
Lichtverteilung herauszupicken andere
unter den Tisch fallen zu lassen und die
die man herauspickt vielleicht sogar
noch zu verstärken das sind eben
Manipulationen
an einem System das so komplex ist dass
es von den meisten Menschen heute noch
nicht hinreichend verstanden wurde
natürliches Licht setzt sich aus vielen
Farben zusammen so auch das Sonnenlicht
dessen Farbspektrum im Regenbogen
sichtbar wird zum Licht der Sonne
gehören aber auch nicht sichtbare
Anteile das Infrarot und das UV-Licht
das Spektrum einer Glühlampe ähnelt dem
der Sonne es ist ebenso kontinuierlich
hat aber einen höheren Anteil an rot und
Infrarot
das Licht einer Kompakt-Leuchtstofflampe
hingegen ist nicht kontinuierlich es
weist lediglich drei Schafe
Energiespitzen auf dazwischen liegende
Farben sind kaum vorhanden der
Schwerpunkt dieses Spektrums liegt im
blauen und grünen Bereich Infrarot fehlt
dem leuchtstofflicht zur Gänze
[Musik]
welchen Sinn hat es aus normalen
Lichtquellen mit denen wir uns ständig
umgeben genau diesen heilsamen
Frequenzbereich oder Spektralbereich
herauszunehmen ich habe eine Folie
praktisch wie ein Prisma und das wissen
wir seit Newton dass man mit einem
Prisma weißes Licht in seine Farbanteile
aufspalten kann und damit Sie jetzt mit
der Kamera das Ganze besser erkennen
können muss ich das ganze hier
einblenden das heißt das Licht kommt in
Form eines Schlitzes hierdurch und dann
ist es eben möglich dass sie einen
Regenbogen sehen also die Farbanteile
dieses weißen Lichtes von rot bis hin
zum violett ohne Unterbrechungen
und wenn ich jetzt die Glühlampe aus
mache und dafür die Energiesparlampe
Einschalten mit der gleichen
Versuchsanordnung dann kann man deutlich
erkennen dass hier zwischen den
einzelnen spärlichen Farbstreifen leere
auftaucht also schwarz bzw eben keine
Farben tatsächlich ist man warm weißes
Licht aus einer Glühlampe prinzipiell
anders aufgebaut als dieses sogenannt
warmweiße Licht aus der Energiesparlampe
den Wärmeanteil wegzulassen das mag den
Techniker begeistern aber mich als Arzt
schockiert ist er
für die Augen älterer Menschen ergeben
sich durch das Licht von
Leuchtstofflampen weitere Probleme
die im Laufe der Jahre gelblich
gewordene Augenlinse Filter den hohen
Blauanteil aus dem Licht von Sparlampen
heraus
dadurch werden diese jedoch als weniger
hell wahrgenommen
[Musik]
Verantwortlicher für Umweltfragen und
Nachhaltigkeit beim internationalen
lichtdesignerverband PLA
er beobachtet seit Jahren den
beherrlichen Aufstieg der
Leuchtstofflampe
bei class Germany's
[Musik]
der Anthropologe und Dokumentarfilme
klaus damniek hat die bereits zuvor in
seinem Film Zwielicht aufgezeigt wie die
Industrie mit Kritik am Licht von
Leuchtstofflampen umgehen
leuchtstofflampenlicht ist Licht wie
jedes andere Licht und das Licht weiß
letztendlich nicht durch welches Prinzip
es erzeugt wurde so dass es heute keine
gesicherten Erkenntnisse gibt dass die
eine Lichtquelle schädlicheres Licht als
die andere erzeugen könnte
im Übrigen kann für viele Aktivitäten im
Innenraum das Tageslicht nach Quantität
und Qualität das heißt auch in Richtung
und Abschirmung besser durch künstliches
nicht nachgebildet werden
besser
nachgebildet werden
diese Einstellung ist sowas von
verbreitet in der Lichtindustrie das ist
erstaunlich wenn man sich damit
beschäftigt die Vorstellung dass Licht
künstlich auf technische Weise
nachgebaut wird ohne dass man die
biologischen Eigenschaften die Wirkung
auf die Körper auf die Organismen
berücksichtigen muss die ist Standard
und es gibt offensichtlich ganz ganz
wenig anders denken der oppositionelle
die die anderen Aspekte mit vertreten
wie weit kommt denn das Licht dass diese
Lampen erzeugen dem Sonnenlicht nahe
ich glaube das interessiert den
Verbraucher an der Stelle nicht ja gut
das war im Herbst 90 nachdem man Film
rausgekommen war hat Greenpeace
Deutschland mich angesprochen die Studie
zu machen mit den Auftrag gegeben
das Ziel der Studie war einmal prüfen zu
lassen ob es Sinn macht Energie zu
sparen durch Leuchtstofflampen
[Musik]
aufgeregt war richtig aufgeregt weil sie
hatten nun endlich ein Thema wo sie mit
neuen Technologien meinten
sparsam mit den Ressourcen umgehen zu
können und dann kommt also ein
unabhängiger daher und sagt ihr habt
leider 75 Fehler da drin und deshalb
Greenpeace stand Mission peoples
pacificated
Greenpeace International hat nichts
Besseres gewusst als die
lampenindustrieumstellung Namen zu beten
die dann also ihren Profis rangesetzt
haben und haben die lichttechnischen
Stellungnahmen
zusammengefasst als
Greenpeace gegen Argument haben sich
also auf die Seite Lichttechnik
geschlagened and anything
that's that Konzept
Greenpeace versucht über ein Büro in
Brüssel die europäische Gesetzgebung zu
beeinflussen
zuständig für Energiepolitik und
Klimawandel ist Mahi sedrid
in den eu-ausschüssen zum Thema
Haushaltslampen die offizielle Position
von Greenpeace
back to 1999
Studio wird übergangen und im Frühjahr
2007 beginnen die Vorbereitungen für das
Verbot der Glühlampe
Greenpeace wird zur Teilnahme an den
Ausschüssen eingeladen
Greenpeace
im Sinne von Klimaschutz ist ist ein
gutes Lobbying und das findet dann hier
sehr schnell eine kritiklose
Unterstützung deswegen hat das
Glühbirnenverbot hier funktioniert
and mercury
und sie begrüßen euphorisch derartige
produktregulierungen und deswegen haben
sie sich an der Stelle meiner Ansicht
nach zu nützlichen Idioten von
Wirtschaftsinteressen gemacht
reality
are professional teaching
[Musik]
thating
have Genesis
wen sind denn schon Glühlampen aus der
Hand gefallen wie viel waren das oder
Energiesparlampen ja wie groß ist das
Thema eigentlich ich bin der Meinung
liegt weit unter 1% sogar
zerbricht eine Energiesparlampe lösen
sich Teile des Leuchtstoffes von der
Innenseite des Glaskolbens dieses Pulver
ist wenn die Lampe einmal gebrannt hat
mit Quecksilber verunreinigt es
entweicht aus der kaputten Glashülle und
wird in die Umwelt freigesetzt sämtliche
Gefäße in denen zerbrochene Lampen
aufbewahrt werden sind in Folge mit
Quecksilber kontaminiert
[Musik]
kaputte Sparlampe der Familie Laus
stammt von einem indischen Hersteller
auch Indien versucht seine
Energieprobleme mit kompakt-
toxics Link ist eine Umweltorganisation
die sich in Indien für ein Verbot von
quecksilberhaltigen Lichtquellen
einsetzt
ich treffe ihren Gründer und
Geschäftsführer Ravi agaval
ist die public
change about the design good feeling
with
deep and digital
[Musik]
finden sich zahllose klein und
Kleinstbetriebe die für den nationalen
wie internationalen marktsparlampen
herstellen
auch für Europa
in Indiens Lichtindustrie werden
jährlich etwa 56 Tonnen Quecksilber
eingesetzt
[Musik]
Quecksilberdampf ist unsichtbar im Labor
lässt sich mittels UV-Licht jedoch
zeigen wie Quecksilber bei
Zimmertemperatur verdampft
[Musik]
wie viele sehen
Afrika in Amerika
gonnaities
in der Studie von Vito der
Entscheidungsgrundlage der EU-Kommission
wird davon ausgegangen dass 80% der
Sparlampen nicht korrekt entsorgt werden
und folglich 80% des Quecksilbers in die
Umwelt gelangen
was aber passiert mit den restlichen 20%
vorschriftsmäßig entsorgten
Energiesparlampen
okay
[Musik]
für die Rücknahme von Leuchtstofflampen
wir haben die die europäische Direktive
wir haben das Elektrogesetz in in
Deutschland und das verpflichtet die
Hersteller dazu diese Lampen
zurückzunehmen und natürlich muss die
Botschaft lauten eine Energiesparlampe
ist in der Nutzung sicherlich eine gute
Sache und sie zu nutzen damit Energie zu
sparen ist
50 60 vielleicht 70%
bereits Sommer vernünftiges ökologischer
handeln die Tatsache dass die Lampen
geringe Mengen an Quecksilber enthalten
ist ja ist ja kein Geheimnis wir gehen
was wir die Hersteller gehen ja auch
sehr sehr offensiv damit um letztlich
im einzelnen sind diese Lampen
tatsächlich dann nicht
gesundheitsgefährdend selbst wenn mal
eine zerbrechen sollte wenn sie dann
entsprechende Handlungsanweisungen mit
lüften und was sonst so empfohlen wird
befolgen dann laufen sie hier nicht
gefahren ihre Gesundheit irgendwas
abträgliches zu tun
[Musik]
ich werde das Gefühl nicht los hier
einen genau geplanten Inszenierung
das gemütliche
arbeitstempel Sauberkeit kann der
Arbeitsalltag in einer Recyclinganlage
so aussehen
wenig später erfahre ich dass die
quecksilbergefahr hier tatsächlich nicht
immer ernst genug genommen wurde
und 23 November 2009 gab der
Geschäftsführer Craig Thompson vor
Gericht zu er sei seiner wie er selbst
formulierte Pflicht bezüglich giftiger
Substanzen nicht nachgekommen
in seiner Recyclinganlage waren 20
Mitarbeiter über Monate einer enormen
Quecksilberbelastung ausgesetzt gewesen
Andresen ist einer von ihnen der
umweltanalytiker absolut gerade eine
Ausbildung zum arbeitsschutzbeauftragten
als ihm an den Arbeitern und sich selbst
erste Symptome auffallen
es event
[Musik]
aufgrund seiner Quecksilber Vergiftung
ist andre heute nicht fähig sondern
erlernten Beruf auszuüben
sind
Zink
und so ist die
die größte Sondermülldeponie der Welt
mit dem hessischen Herr von Neurode hier
befinden sich 220.000 Tonnen
quecksilberhaltige Abfälle
da die Ausfuhr von Quecksilber aus
Europa verboten ist wird es hier
zwischengelagert
der für das Verbot der Glühlampe
verantwortliche EU-Kommissar ist anderes
biebikes ein Interview mit mir Länder ab
es sei nicht mehr Kommissar für Energie
also nicht mehr zuständig
sein Nachfolger Günther Oettinger
verweigert ebenso das Gespräch er sei
zwar Kommissar für Energie aber damals
noch nicht zuständig gewesen
ich werde schließlich auf die Sprecherin
Oettingers verwiesen der für die
Vorbereitung der Verordnung zuständige
Beamte sitzt im Hintergrund er darf
nicht gefilmt werden wie viel
Quecksilber freigesetzt wird hat für die
Entscheidung der Kommission
offensichtlich keine Rolle gespielt
es ist zwar richtig dass in den neuen
Lampen ein ganz kleiner Teil Quecksilber
drin vorkommt aber wenn man die
Gesamtrechnung macht wenn man bedenkt
dass durch diese Lampen sehr viel
Energie gespart wird und es ist nun mal
so dass in Europa immer noch Kohle
verbrannt wird um Energie zu erzeugen
und da sehr viel Quecksilber freigesetzt
wird sparen wir in der Summe sehr viel
mehr Quecksilber ein
vom sogenannten Quecksilber Paradoxon
habe ich zu diesem Zeitpunkt bereits
öfter gehört
Kevin Jean fährt mit mir zu einem
Kohlekraftwerk das seit den späten 60er
Jahren im Betrieb ist
das
spannend
mercurity
life of
reaching Praxis
American call which is Johny higher in
Bells Mercurial
the problems
the differentin the mercurity from
von people work and level the Parkplatz
das sind matter how much energy is being
Consum by lighting at residential level
and ifits gonna better we are not
nothing is gonna change von the point of
you of the level of production of
electricity and the level of the power
plant so whatever there pro using
change dessen
wie viel CO2 sollte durch die Verordnung
1244 2009 eingespart werden
etwa 15 Millionen Tonnen CO2 einsparen
werden nur durch die Glühlampe 15
Millionen Tonnen sind gerade mal 0,4%
des europäischen CO2 Ausstoßes selbst
wenn man annimmt das 15 Millionen Tonnen
CO2 eingespart werden würde ist die Zahl
lächerlich klein ähm im Vergleich zu
anderen Ländern china hat einen Ausstoß
an CO2 von mehr als 5 Milliarden Tonnen
jährlich und der diese Ausstoß steigt um
etwa 500 Millionen Tonnen pro Jahr
[Musik]
der europäischen CO2-Emission
das ist sehr wenig werden
dann stellen Sie diese Frage nochmal und
ich beantworte sie ja okay
welche Bedeutung hat das
Glühlampenverbot für die europäische
Energiepolitik wenn man bedenkt dass
Zentrum für europäische
Wirtschaftsforschung nur vier Promille
CO2-Produktion Europas dadurch
eingespart werden
ja ich glaube es werden Irrtum zu
glauben und wir haben das nie geglaubt
dass die Glühbirne allein
unsere fahren wird sie ist ein Teil
einer weiteren Politik wir haben auch
Waschmaschinen wo es
energieeffizienzlebel gibt wir haben
Kühlschränke wir haben andere
Energieeffizienzmaßnahmen die Gebäude
müssen besser renoviert werden wir haben
auch vorgeschrieben dass wir viel mehr
in Erneuerbare Energie investieren in
Wind und so weiter also die Glühbirne
ist ein kleiner Teil aber ein Teil einer
weiteren Politik die uns hoffentlich
hilft das Klima wirklich erfolgreich zu
bekämpfen
weniger Stromverbrauch im Haushalt
bedeutet weniger Stromproduktion im
Kraftwerk und in Folge weniger
CO2-Ausstoß die gesamte Emission von CO2
in Europa ist für besonders
CO2-intensive Industriesektoren jedoch
durch den Emissionshandel verbindlich
festgelegt das Recht CO2 zu imitieren
kann in Form von Zertifikaten
weiterverkauft werden sollte ein Sektor
also weniger co2-ausstoßen darf ein
anderer um genau diesen Wert mehr
Zertifikate erwerben und mehr CO2
imitieren die Gesamtmenge an erzeugtem
CO2 aber bleibt immer gleich das
Glühlampenverbot ist also wirkungslos
[Musik]
Politik mit umweltseitigen Wirkung ist
überhaupt nicht zu rechnen
der Glühlampe wird von Seiten ihrer
Gegner gerne vorgeworfen sie würde bis
zu 95% dazu geführten Energie in
wärmeumwandeln
zweifindige Ingenieure aus Deutschland
haben diese Schwäche in einen Vorteil
ungewünscht
die Formgebung
klassisch
so dass doch keine Missverständnisse
aufkommen können
die Funktionsweise ähnlich der alten
Glühbirne aber
die bestimmungsgemäße Verwendung ist
einfach das Heizen ja und damit kommen
wir auch von unglaublich guten
Wirkungsgrad der fast seine 100% angeht
wir haben leider noch das Problem dass
uns immer Licht verloren geht aber viele
Kunden finden das sogar ganz gut und
deshalb haben wir diese diese Glashülle
auch beibehalten und haben sie nicht
abgedunkelt und vor allen Dingen passt
es Ihnen die ehemaligen jetzt frei
gewordenen Lampenfassung
eine vom britischen Umweltministerium in
Auftrag gegebenes Studie belegt das 21%
jener Energie die in Leuchtmittel
investiert wird übers Jahr gemittelt bei
der Heizung gespart werden kann
besonders deutlich wird diese Effekt bei
Passivhäusern
jeder Bewohner dieses Hauses bringt
Energie ein die Küche die ich benutze
die Geräte die ich verwende egal ob das
Fernsehen
bringt mir für das gesamte
Energiekonzept einen Gewinn natürlich
auch die Glühlampe wenn ich keine
Glühlampe verwende heißt das ich muss
die von der Glühlampe
freigesetzte Wärme anderweitig gewinnen
energetisch geändert seit sie
energiespannung benutzen müssen ja ich
muss den fehlenden Energieeintrag der
Glühbirne natürlich kompensieren und das
Heizregister kommt wesentlich öfter zum
Einsatz als es zuvor der Fall war
die Produktion ist in China und die
Chinesen haben sich auch nicht beteiligt
sondern eher Lebensdauer Begrenzung
aber ich bin mit der Qualität dieser
ersten Lieferung auf jeden Fall sehr
zufrieden ich finde damit kann man auch
ein bisschen mal
Protest zeigen und kann vielleicht den
Leuten auch mal die Augen öffnen was
alles für ein Blödsinn mitgemacht wird
in diesem Land und in den Nachbarländern
eben auch
hier befinden wir uns in einem Bereich
der nicht von
europäischen Mächten kontrolliert wird
so dass hier auch Keyboards herstellbar
sind die eine längere Lebenszeit haben
wir zahlen hier einen dreifach höheren
Preis wir könnten den Preis hier runter
verhandeln und versuchen alles
auszuquetschen aber sieht voll ist kein
normales Handelsprodukt wir wollen
keinen Gewinn mit diesem Produkt machen
sondern es ist für uns eine
Kunst eine widerstandskunde gegen
Prozesse die in Europa laufen
die Industrie scheint immer wieder eine
starke Lobby zu haben der normale Bürger
scheint eine solche Lobby nicht zu haben
und wir versuchen hier eine Gleichheit
herzustellen und eine Lobby für den
Verbraucher darzustellen
wir sind keine
speedballhändler nein wir sind normale
Bürger die sich mit dem Thema
auseinandergesetzt haben und sie sich
als Bürger darüber aufgeregt haben dass
ein so undemokratisches Gesetz entsteht
wenn es um das Glühlampen verboten geht
verstehen die Behörden keinen Spaß der
Argumentation keine Lampen sondern
kleinheitsgeräte wird nicht Folge
geleistet
erfüllen demnach nicht die Anforderungen
der EU-Verordnung
40.000 bereits bestellte Heatballs
werden deshalb vom Zoll einbehalten sie
dürfen nicht innerhalb der Europäischen
Union in Verkehr gebracht werden
ja ich sag mal wer da eine politische
Brille auf hat der kann der hat den
Blick für die Wahrheit glaube ich
verloren wir haben aber seinerzeit schon
gesagt dass wir das als Kunstaktion
sehen und sollte man uns daran hindern
unsere Kunstaktion bis zum Ende zu
bringen wir auch einen langen Atem haben
und wenn man uns dazu zwingt denke ich
sind wir als Bürger auch aufgefordert
Standfestigkeit und Mut zu beweisen
Pflicht zum wach sein ja und dafür zu
sorgen dass man durch den Finger zeigt
auf bestimmte Missstände es erreichen
kann dass sich auch etwas verändert und
ich meine das ist sind die Grundfeste
unsere Staatswesen so meine jetzt meine
Schule gelernt zu haben und deshalb
nehme ich jetzt auch diesen Kampf für
mich in Anspruch um dort vielleicht
einen kleinen Beitrag zu leisten dass
Menschen aufmerksam werden und einmal
als hinterfragen was hat es eigentlich
mit dieser
EU-Verordnung auf sich und welchen Sinn
hat sich macht sie wirklich einen Dienst
an der Umwelt und der Menschen oder
haben wir uns da ein Bären aufbinden
lassen
[Musik]
heute geht es Max etwas besser welche
Langzeitschäden bei Unfall mit der
Energiesparlampe bei ihm hinterlässt
wird die Zukunft zeigen
in einem Bild hat Max einen größten
Wunsch ausgedrückt seine Haare sollen
wieder nachgewachsen sein wenn in die
Schule kommt und so sagte ihr Haus soll
wieder ohne Gift sein
wir haben in den letzten Jahren und
Jahrzehnten wirklich überhaupt nichts
gelernt wir müssen einfach irgendwo
sehen wir leben in einer Zivilisation in
einer modernen Gesellschaft wo ganz
offenbar Wirtschaftswachstum vor
Volksgesundheit kommt wenn ich sehe was
an Sicherheitsvorschriften die für alle
anderen Produkte gelten für die
Energiesparlampe außer Kraft gesetzt
wurde dann ist das für mich wirklich
eine Aushebung dem der Demokratie da ist
eben über diese Mischung Ausgesteuerten
Expertisen bezahlten Expertisen drückt
der Industrie Möglichkeit für die
Politik sich zu positionieren mit einem
Thema ist ein Druck geschaffen worden
der wirklich nicht nur die Demokratie
aushebelt sondern auch Recht und Gesetz
aushebelt
wird only Europe
Citiz come together and thing we need to
change
dürfen
[Musik]
wir haben die besseren Argumente auf
unserer Seite und werden insofern diesen
Prozess am Ende schon gewinnen
[Musik]